hehe
my strength
wikipedia would request that theoretician of
our business plan vince live the
war of the roses rap jazz awards soil
since they allow us to give and here
and you also become edenor
strange camping and without an egg and being goes
well to gray to me  has provided and does not
require in crystal logic in English
and not that of the world by car in Colombia in
reggaeton to be in the public for a
rental reader
in the will of various characters in
web
panic attack enhancement meditation
control
[Music]
in  this lawsuit is about frei money,
always for pensions
[Music]
there is a slave to anda de moringa
direct justin bieber nine laps very
good for giving me back the injury systole
flamini of the centrals put in contention
the movement of the email at this moment
of no kim  jong is this
yamila reformism and like everything now that delicious
in miami are the light a valdés ford
type that country the coaching link
on youtube live
goes jones
[Laughter]
[Music]
with your law
imagine yourself
ready battle studies
ok
in israel and how about the million
views of rosalía's video it's
incredible
another billion more
of several videos that we have and I won't
change it and I'm going to try to talk about elvis
in this is one more  for the car but it
came out with height sambil and facebook next they
are saying that button and the valley
but not from the area the great 10 and
realized who they were a big one was not necessary it
was the dj set show they are webs not
suitable that find the sources and  being a
set fire lobby is worth several large ones already
launched a large area
valbuena coal and gets along well with a turn
the wind and wessis many tell me it has
abounded natural in a surprise mission
when the reading mine we know it
red bull of the natural extend the
attack on this commission
now says for erviti of the lost souls
dancing municipal
for the selection are the acronyms places
gradation security they ask is you tell me
with this way diversity and
saving the  skirt without james bond
I'm the oldest and I have a Latin festival
well down here mostly I don't know I don't know
how much they're worth but the work started
that's why next that way the respective baby
can culture of pioneer of chronicle in
Colombia eckstein formula jay bybee
patent
in Colombia
no you don't need anything
anymore you don't need anything anymore of course that
I need it I don't need anything
that depending on
people they can't base themselves on the
material so that nothing is missing there are
many things that one would like to have
around people  hugs I could you
at a
live level amy house and friends and
iy sneijder
these rehearsals led to when they have the
guinness record for the most
repeated song in a concert by the way it is
sensational that night it gives me I think we
have to do it again because why
smooth  Cádiz
says the foster song 12 times
and I'm the only one who comes in every once in a
while to see how many views it has if I
don't make the entire video for my people
[Music]